bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france que répond le
médecin que vous êtes parce qu'elle sort
et aux manifestants qui jugent
liberticide le passe à lithaire et
l'obligation vaccinale pour certaines
professions
bonsoir mâcha ça m'interroge en fait
c'est vrai que sur un point de vue
purement théorique l'obligation
généralisée ça peut interroger beaucoup
de monde d'un autre côté
on voit bien que la contamination
continuent on voit bien que les cas
persiste peut-être que la forme n'est
pas idéale mais se battre en disant que
c'est liberticide je crois qu'il ya plus
d'un an quand on était haut pour la
première vague tout le monde attendait
qu'on fasse quelque chose maintenant
qu'on a un vaccin qu'une certaine
efficacité qu'elle aurait moins un effet
protecteur vis-à-vis des formes graves
maintenant les gens se plaisent
et je sais pas je ne comprends pas je
comprends plus en fait du côté de
l'école en revanche pas de passer à
lutter à la rentrée ce que vous saluer
cette décision et que la ghière
jeu alors à titre personnel déjà je suis
vacciné depuis mai juin je ne suis pas
pour le pass annie terre dans le sens où
je déteste tout ce qui peut faire des
différences entre les gens les exemples
dans l'histoire ont toujours étaient
nocifs sans forcément invoqué la seconde
guerre mondiale très raisonnable enfin
ça reste pas terrible je trouve de faire
des différences entre les gens d'autant
plus qu'il est ce qui me dérange en fait
c'est que se passe l air est incohérent
en groupe pour céder à des lobbys on va
dire dans le métro aucun risque c'est
absurde en centre commercial aucun
risque en revanche en terrasse de café
il faut le pal sanitaire c'est absurde
nous dans les classes qu'on va être de
nouveau 35 par salle avec le coït qui
continuent à circuler lgv alors le vario
indien qui est plus contaminant toujours
aucune réelle mesure on est toujours
exposé toujours en danger d'ailleurs le
reproche qu'on pourrait faire aux gens
qui ont promu le vaccin c'est de ne pas
avoir été honnête qui crée du
complotisme ils ont été responsables de
créer du complotisme quand on entend que
huit personnes sur dix ans rien ne sont
pas vaccinés ça veut dire que deux sur
dix leçons à partir de là il fallait un
discours transparent dire que le vaccin
était pas terrible qu'il était correct
mais pas terrible et que c'était mieux
que rien mais pas génial ça n'a jamais
quasiment été dit on à une propagande à
ce niveau là et quand on fait une
propagande baron face il ya du
complotisme qui n'est donc les
politiques et certains médecins sont
responsables en n'ayant pas été honnête
à l'école ça va être dangereux
l'institut pasteur 10 50 mille
contamination d'enfants par jour les
parents se retrouvent à nous expliquer
que c'est pas grave parce que leurs
enfants connaissent pas grand-chose
bannu risque quelque chose donc c'est
bien gentil de penser qu'à son enfant
mais c'est peut-être important de penser
à la société dans son ensemble aussi
bref je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de cash
willie h beaucoup d'incohérences depuis
deux ans les stylos rouges dénoncent on
a même porté plainte contre jean-michel
blanc perd ça pour près de la cour de
justice de la république une gestion
absurde incohérente mal fait et cette
rentrée s'annonce de nouveau dangereuse
pour tout le monde
nous on ne veut pas de pass and it
heures à l'école on ne veut pas faire de
différence entre les élèves mais en
revanche on veut être protégé on veut
que les élèves soient protégés les
familles aussi et la conclusion est
simple ce n'est pas fait ce n'est pas
près personne n'est près rien n'est prêt
au contraire de ce que raconte dans les
chais blond clair sur cette question me
pascale forêt de la communication qui a
entouré les vaccins qu'est ce que vous
répondez à nicolas guerre
alors c'est évident que depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire depuis le mois de
mars 2020 il ya un problème de
communication j'ai été le premier à le
dire sur cette antenne l'ajustement par
contre ce que dit monsieur grier
concernant les squats et des vaccins
c'est un fake news concrètement sur le
terrain et je vous parle de terrain je
vous parle pas d'information je ne parle
pas de revue je vous parle pas de blog
parce que les complotistes leurs sources
sont des blogs
concrètement nous avons plus de 80% des
gens hospitalisés qui ne sont pas
vaccinés le vaccin est efficace contre
les formes graves est efficace contre
les décès contre les hospitalisations
contre les passages en réanimation et
dans 66% des cas si sur les derniers
chiffres américains qui ont 15 jours il
est efficace pour ne pas développer la
maladie du tout et ne pas la transmettre
donc ça c'est un chai le vaccin est
efficace oui après concernant l'école
le pass sanitaires et exigé la
vaccination pour tous l'obligation du
masque alors le masque on peut en parler
vous allez au cinéma les gens mettent le
mas des classes séance commence on
enlève le masque pour quoi faire le
français de base n'aime pas respecter ne
pas respecter les règles donc forcément
dès qu'on lui impose une règle il va
tout faire pour la contourner protéger
l'école oui bien sûr et les enfants là
depuis quelques semaines je sais pas si
vous suivez l'actualité on commence à
avoir des cas d'enfants hospitalisés
avec des formes graves on a des maladies
inflammatoires costco vie qui
apparaissent
le syndrome inflammatoire multi
systémique pédiatrique c'est une entité
qui n'existait quasiment pas qui était
extrêmement rare en france on est à plus
de 500 cas c'est énorme donc les enfants
ne sont pas plus épargné que les autres
après protéger les enseignants mais bien
sûr l'école va être le premier foyer de
contamination mais quelle solution on aa
par le vaccin les masques les
purificateurs d'air
ce sont les bons j'ai pas d'autre
solution ils se sont bien les points
qu'a annoncé jean michel blanquer il y a
quelques jours dans ce protocole
sanitaire qui sera donc mise en place à
partir de mardi port du masque à
l'intérieur renforcement de l'aération
des locaux dépistage aussi dépistage
salivaire avec cet objectif de 600 mille
tests réalisés chaque semaine malgré
tout nicolas glières où vous restez
inquiet al'approche de cette rentrée
scolaire
comme je vous l'aï dit sur rtl
l'an dernier nous sommes inquiets
exactement de la même manière avec ce
varillon plus dangereux les mesures ne
sont pas prises il n'y a aucun
purificateurs d'air dans les écoles le
budget est trop lourd pour les communes
dont il faudrait que ce soit l'état
l'éducation nationale qui s'en charge ça
n'est pas prêt ce n'est pas fait en fait
non la meilleure mesure n'est ni le
vaccin même s'il est utile je ne nie pas
du tout on a dit on a donné les mêmes
chiffres vu le signal monsieur huit sur
dix ça veut dire deux sur dix qu'ils
développent même en étant vacciner voilà
c'est majoritairement efficace mais pas
toujours et en fait il faut surtout la
distanciation sociale c'est le meilleur
moyen de ne pas apporter de ne pas
attraper ou transmettre le virus c'est à
dire des demies groupe s'il le faut
encore une fois je les ai répétés mille
fois sur rtl ailleurs les deux mig
groupe ne sont pas comment dire un idéal
ne sont pas géniaux mais c'est toujours
mieux que rien mieux vaut cela que de
répandre l'épidémie est en fait on a
beau le répéter à cor et à cri on a
toujours des parents qui hurlent en
disant que ça les empêche de faire des
réunions inutiles à leur boulot ou
d'aller se promener ou de voir des amis
je suis désolé l'école n'est pas une
garderie elle doit être protégée nous
sommes là pour transmettre pour
enseigner et l'école n'est pas là pour
arranger les parents elle est là pour
transmettre mais si cette transmission
est dangereuse à cause d'une épidémie eh
bien on adapte on s'adapte ce qui a
manqué en france c'est une adaptation
les entreprises en majorité ont refusé
de jouer le jeu du télétravail les gens
ont continué à aller bosser parce qu'il
trouvait que c'était plus sympa les
parents voulu continuer ce que les
enfants se sont tassés à 35 par salle
pour ne pas avoir à se retrouver parfois
trois jours c'est ce qui s'est passé en
mai avec leurs chères têtes blondes je
suis désolé quand on a des enfants on
s'en occupe quand on a des enfants on
assume et achu mais c'est parfois
protégés 16 enfants soi-même et la
population et les profs au hasard comme
ça d'une d'un virus dangereux je répète
je ne minimise pas le virus je ne laisse
pas son danger je sais que le vaccin est
efficace dans l'absolu puisque j'ai
accepté d'être vaccinés on mais je vais
pas accepter ya trois jours simplement
je n'aime pas je le répète le côté
obligatoire je pense que c'est mal
expliqué que quand on assène des vérités
mensongères aux jambes a forcément ils
doutent ils ont loi doutey et que ça ne
peut peut créer du complotisme et du
doute à ce niveau là argelès et ça que
je vous laisse répondre à pascal serais
je voudrais avoir ainsi votre regard sur
cette rentrée ce que vous la redoute est
ce que vous redoutiez est ce que vous
redoutez que redémarre dans quelques
scènes dans quelques semaines à cette
épidémie que gide ça je suis tout à fait
d'accord je suis pas complètement
contradictoire avec monsieur au
contraire de toute façon la vue dès que
les une rentrée scolaire que ça peu
après des petites vacances ou des
grandes vacances
le nombre de câbles a réaugmenté
ça c'est sûr qu'on va avoir de nouveau
une flambée l'épidémie là ça se calme un
petit peu parce que ben les vacances se
terminent les gens rentrent il ya moins
de brassage de population mais dès qu'il
va y avoir un brassage de population on
va se retrouver qu'une augmentation du
nombre de cas
je dirai ce qui se passe en outre-mer en
guadeloupe au risque de nous arriver
très très vite et c'est vrai que des
grands rassemblements comme elle est
comme ça peut poser des vraies vrai
problème s'agit par contre je suis
vraiment à 100% et il faut protéger
cette contamination à terre personne
voilà oui je suis plutôt d'accord merci
à tous les deux d'avoir participé à cet
échange a dit que nicolas biliaire
enseignants membres décident roja et
vous pascal serait médecins généralistes
merci beaucoup à bientôt de serrières
défense